to find his birth parents ended up
playing matchmaker Martin Schmidt's
biological mother and father had not
spoken since high school they put him up
for adoption 36 years ago
Lana Marin duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn spoke with all three of
them about their unique love story lad
good morning good morning Martin Schmidt
knew he was adopted but it wasn't until
he found out he was going to be a father
that he decided to seek out his birth
parents the next four years would unfold
just like a movie one with a happy
ending this moment captured on cell
phone video was more than three decades
in the making but the journey to get
here an alter under a tent in rural
Wisconsin was a journey of heartbreak
pain but most of all love the parents
that adopted me have always been super
supportive 36 year old Martin Schmidt
was a newborn when he was adopted his
birth mother Michelle Newman was just 16
years old when she found out she was
pregnant several months after she and
her high school boyfriend Dave Lindgren
broke up I struggled with the decision I
just prayed adoption was the best choice
do you ever stop thinking about him
never yeah Michelle and Dave went their
separate ways after Martin's adoption
Michelle moved to Hawaii
Dave stayed in Wisconsin and had several
biological and stepchildren in 2014 with
a baby of his own on the way Martin got
in contact with his birth mom she in
turn reached out to Dave we talked until
2 o'clock that morning surround a phone
in probably 3 hours and it just it just
felt natural like we just picked up from
17 18 years old again and then later in
the month you know she's like well why
don't you come out to Hawaii their
connection and chemistry was instant
when I got off the plane in Hawaii and
and walked down at Airport stairs I
could just see that he felt this I felt
that it yes did you Michelle yes would
you feel a connection just like I saw
him and I saw his smiles like I remember
that I know this guy that trip led to
dating eventually Michelle moved back to
Wisconsin and the couple's relationship
with each other and Martin blossomed
when you look at the man that he's
become the father that he is what goes
through your mind he's a great man so
watch him with his kids he's just
connects with them he's attention to
them sees them his parents did a great
job right I couldn't ask for for
anything better to find in early August
Dave and Michelle tied the knot and
Martin officiated you know I think that
the reason that this is working out so
well is that these are really good
people what have you learned from just
this entire process of rediscovery
miracles do happen for me it's just you
know never give up hope dreams can come
true and there's a lot of love out there
in the world Martin told us the
acceptance and support from his adoptive
parents and his big sister made all the
difference in reconnecting with his
birth parents
Martin's adoptive and birth parents are
both involved in the lives of his
children and I can tell you that there
was not I mean there were tears in my
eyes throughout the process of
interviewing them because it's such a
beautiful story and on so many levels
yes fact that they got together she
didn't have any other children no and
how great it is to find somebody that
makes you feel how you felt when you
were 17 and 18 years old and it's that
person it is that person and you know
when you see their pictures of them in
high school yeah you get the sense of
how young they were children and so that
the reason that she gave up Martin for
adoption is and that child Martin
brought it back together and do you glad
thank you you're Arden Thank You Vlad a
great story